protest gegen den krieg den gab es heute
auch in russland in mehreren städten wie
hier in tomsk und moskau mehr als 3000
festnahmen soll es gegeben haben die
humanitäre lage spitzt sich in der
ukraine weiter zu besonders betroffen
die hafenstadt mario pohl erneut
scheiterte der versuch menschen während
einer feuerpause in sicherheit zu
bringen
herzlich willkommen auch heute wieder zu
einem zdf spezial
wir jeden gleich ab an theo koll und
berlin direkt doch zunächst wollen wir
noch mal genauer erfahren wie es den
menschen in der ukraine geht vor allem
in dem umkämpften mario pohl seit tagen
melden hilfsorganisationen dass es kaum
wasser strom oder lebensmittel mehr gibt
darüber reden möchte ich jetzt mit
christian katzer von ärzte ohne grenzen
haircuts abbas sind in ihrer information
über die lage in mario pohl
guten abend er hat seine grenzen hat ein
team in mario pohl wir haben zum glück
vor einigen wochen schon materialien in
die ukraine bringen können die wir jetzt
in den letzten tagen an krankenhäuser in
mario pohl verteilen konnten leider
gehen auch diese versorgung zur neige
und wir haben moment keine möglichkeit
weitere materialien die stadt lingen
kolleginnen stehen im kontakt mit dem
team und den kolleginnen in mario pohl
und natürlich sind wir sehr besorgt die
lage ist sehr unübersichtlich es wird
seit tagen tag und nacht geschossen und
bombardiert
die kolleginnen berichten dass die
supermärkte leer sind die apotheken sind
leer es gibt kein trinkwasser
und auch die stromversorgung
zusammengebrochen so dass zum beispiel
eine elektrische heizung nicht mehr
funktionieren und das im moment bei
minusgraden
wir sind sehr besorgt über die lage und
wünschen uns natürlich dass wir den
menschen in mariupol in der ukraine
prinzipiell medizinische versorgung
zukommen lassen können wir können deine
hilfsorganisationen dort überhaupt noch
helfen
letztendlich ist es so dass aufgrund der
sehr sich sehr schnell verändern den
militärischen lage es ist sehr schwierig
ist überhaupt den bedarf der menschen zu
ermitteln was wir natürlich sehen ist
das eine weiterführende
gesundheitsversorgung einfach nötig ist
und vielen gebieten ist diese dann
zusammengebrochen aber sie können sich
vorstellen schwangere frauen oder
menschen mit chronischen erkrankungen
brauchen natürlich einen zugang zu
gesundheitsversorgung
es braucht sie brauchen täglich
medikamente und wir versuchen uns gerade
mit spezialteams darauf einzustellen und
da wo die hilfe am nötigsten ist dann
unter zu unterstützen heute ist ja auch
der zweite versuch gescheitert die
menschen aus mario pohl herauszubringen
über eine flucht korridor hier sehen wir
eine karte der weg führt von mario pohl
über 200 kilometer richtung nordwesten
nach sapporo es ja was heißt das
scheitern für die lage der
zivilbevölkerung
grundsätzlich ist zu sagen dass
zivilisten kritischen kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung immer und zu jeder
zeit geschützt sein müssen das gilt
übrigens für alle konfliktparteien alle
militärischen verbände und alle kämpfen
denn menschen vor ort dass zivilisten
und zivile infrastruktur immer geschützt
ist natürlich kann es in solchen
momenten wie jetzt
sehr nötig seien feuerpausen oder auch
diese korridore zu vereinbaren aber
wichtig ist für uns noch mal zu betonen
dass
auch wenn diese zeit
verstreichen wenn wenn waffenruhe
verstreichen oder wenn solche korridore
aufgehen oder wie in diesem fall jetzt
halt nicht funktionieren das
zivilistinnen immer geschützt sind auch
wenn sie sich entscheiden dort zu
bleiben es gibt natürlich auch kranke
und verletzte die sie können sich nicht
wegbewegen und es gibt immer wieder
medizinisches personal was natürlich bei
diesen menschen bleibt und auch diese
menschen sind geschützt wenn sie nach
verstreichen einer solchen waffenruhe
oder eines angebots zu einer humanitären
korridor weiter in dem umkämpften gebiet
bleiben vielen dank christian katzer
vielen dank
die not ist in mario pohl besonders groß
doch das ist nur ein brennpunkt in
diesem krieg in dem russland auch weiter
versucht kirch zu umzingeln die
militärischen angriff auf großstädte
fortsetzt seit tagen sind wir in kontakt
mit ukraine und bitten sie uns ihre lage
zu schildern via skype mit
handyaufnahmen hier ihre schilderungen
wir versteckten uns immer noch
ich gehe nicht mal mehr in den garten im
herbst habe ich dort einige blumen
gepflanzt ich bin nicht einmal mehr
hingegangen um nach ihm zu sehen ich
kann einfach nicht ich habe angst die
meiste zeit verbringe ich in diesem raum
manchmal bin ich noch in der küche oder
der dusche das ist alles ich weiß im
moment sind sie nicht da es wird nicht
geschossen aber das hat nichts an meiner
angst
ich weiß nicht ob das hier nicht mein
letztes gespräch ist ich schreibe meinem
freund die ganze zeit dass ich ihn liebe
weil ich nicht weiß welche nachricht
welche nachricht die letzte sein könnte
es ist schwer zu erklären wie es in
unseren herzen aussieht
heute haben wir gehört dass auch unsere
heimatstadt bombardiert wird
als ich sah dass sie auch zivilisten in
kharkiv bombardieren habe ich verstanden
dass sie nicht nur gegen soldaten
kämpfen ich habe verstanden dass sie
auch uns zivilisten töten wollen
aber ich will nicht dass meine familie
den terror eines völkermords miterleben
muss deshalb habe ich beschlossen meinen
heimatort zu verlassen den ort wo mein
vater und mein großvater begraben sind
auch meine mutter musste ich verlassen
weil sie nicht mitkommen wollte
klopf klopf denkmal wir sind im
fernsehen
das sind frauen aus dem dorf die uns
helfen
und hier kochen wir
früher war es ein camp unserer kirche
und das wird es hoffentlich auch wieder
aber jetzt hat dieses camp eine andere
aufgabe jetzt ist es ein camp für
flüchtende in dem menschen auf ihrer
flucht halt machen einen unterschlupf
haben etwas zu essen
nachdem du zehn tage lang in
schutzbunker gesessen hast und dann bist
du in einem raum jemand schließt die tür
im gebäude und du denkst oh mein gott
was ist das für ein geräusch was was ist
das was ist das fängt das jetzt ja auch
an ja sie sind absolut gestresst einfach
erschöpft
eine familie kam in einem wenn neun
personen und die oma konnte nicht mehr
laufen sie war bettlägerig
aber ihre enkelkinder haben sie einfach
auf ihren händen getragen und sie sagten
wo können wir sie hinbringen kann sie
etwas zu essen bekommen kann sie bitte
mit unserem großvater zusammen ein
zimmer
das ist etwas was uns ukraine ausmacht
wenn schwere zeiten kommen versuchen wir
sie gemeinsam zu überstehen
wahrscheinlich sind wieder einige
flüchtende gekommen und sie bekommen
gerade etwas zu essen
sie sagen alle dank sei gott weil sie
überlebt haben
ja das waren eindrucksvolle stimmen aus
der ukraine deren präsident wladimir
seelands immer wieder um hilfe aus dem
westen bittet jähriger geht deutschland
über die zeiten wenn der deutschen
politik jetzt mehr bei berlin direkt und
theo koll wir melden uns danach wieder
vielen dank herr pieper die welt die wir
kannten ist mit einem schlag
untergegangen der russische überfall hat
auch jahrzehntelange politische tabus
weggewischt wir sprechen darüber gleich
mit dem vizekanzler robert habeck und
der spd chefin saskia s und damit
willkommen zu berlin direkt es ist ein
krieg der unser land die deutschen
parteien massiv verändern wird aus
abrüstungs parteien werden auf rüstungs
parteien aus einer liberalen an die
schulden partei wird die partei
gigantischer schattenhaushalte und bei
den grünen scheinen
laufzeitverlängerungen bisher abgelehnte
energieform nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
der koalitionsvertrag hat nur noch
historischen wert was aber macht das mit
der dna der ampel parteien thomas
reichert berichtet
präsident putin hatten mit seinem
überfall auf die ukraine eine neue
realität geschaffen
diese neue realität erfordert eine klare
es ist eine antwort die noch vor kurzem
undenkbar schien waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine härteste finanzsanktionen
gegen russland mehr noch stolz für die
bundeswehr aufrüsten mit einem
sondervermögen der bundeshaushalt 2022
wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig mit
100 milliarden euro ausstatten die
mittel werden der für notwendige
investitionen
am sonntag vor einer woche bekommt
kanzler chance für all das stehen deiner
platz es ist ein ko der scholz aus der
rolle des zauberers an die spitze der
anti putin allianz katapultiert der
führung bestellt bekommt sie bei mir hat
scholz mal gesagt in den tagen danach
aber wächst die zahl derer in der ampel
die sich fragen ob sie das was sie nun
bekommen wirklich bestellt haben was
china verlangt ist für viele eine
zumutung aber die viel größeres putins
krieg deshalb öffentlich keine kritik
das kaum jemand eingeweiht war in den
100 milliarden plan
wir haben als ampel eine gute praxis und
die heißt dass wir interne dinge
miteinander besprechen und nicht
übereinander reden und das ist wichtig
für eine erfolgreiche koalition unter
anhalten wir uns doch die furcht ist
groß dass von den ursprünglichen ampel
plänen in kriegszeiten wenig übrig
bleibt ihr versprechen mehr fortschritte
wagen hatte viele kapitel das zur
sicherheitspolitik aber kam erst weit
hinten schien nicht so wichtig jetzt
überragt die frage nach krieg und
frieden alles andere was bleibt ist die
hoffnung des urlaubs scholz der fraktion
zugesichert hat dass neben diesem
sondervermögen natürlich weiter an den
prioritären aufgaben des
koalitionsvertrages gearbeitet wird was
den klimaschutz betrifft was den umbau
der arbeits des wirtschaftens aber auch
wohnen und öffentlicher
personennahverkehr alles das wird
erhalten bleiben
es ist nicht das erste mal dass krieg
eine kollektion zu etwas zwingt auf dass
sie nicht vorbereitet war
1999 rot-grün beteiligt sich im rahmen
der nato im kosovo krieg um weitere
serbische massaker zu verhindern es ist
der erste kampfeinsatz deutscher
soldaten seit dem zweiten weltkrieg und
er hätte die grünen damals fast
zerrissen
und heute die situation ist überhaupt
nicht vergleichbar erstens weil wir
damals sehr frisch mit der verantwortung
betraut wurden heute sind wir in zehn
bundesländern in der regierung und es
ist nichts erst einmal dass wir regieren
und außerdem ist auch das niveau der
aggression einfach ein ganz anderes wir
reden nicht über ein kosovo wir reden
über eine atommacht direkt an unserer
grenze genau das wie mit der atommacht
russland umgehen war eine frage die
anfang der 80er jahre die spd spaltete
300.000 demonstrierten in bonn gegen den
nato doppelbeschluss
kanzler helmut schmidt der für
verhandlungen und abschreckung eintrat
wird die zunehmend isoliert
die tradition der friedensbewegung die
abneigung gegen abschreckung das spielt
auch heute eine rolle
das was jetzt eine zeitenwende ist ist
in der tat von präsident putin zu
verantworten dass wir die letzten 20
jahre aber auch erleben mussten das
einseitig rüstungsverträge
abrüstungsverträge gekündigt wurden dass
es keine vertrauensbildung mehr gegeben
hat das ist ja auch klare realität und
da müssen wir auch konsequenzen
ausziehen bei spd und grünen gibt es nun
forderungen das schutzpaket dem
parlament zu verändern wenn schon
rüstung dann mit zivile krisenprävention
und die klimawende bekommt ein zusatz
argument putin wir müssen
schnellstmöglich von russischem gas
kohle und öl unabhängig werden dafür
braucht es milliarden investition dafür
darf die schuldenbremse nicht im weg
stehen dafür dürfen auch die versprechen
beispielsweise keine steuern für reiche
oder vermögende zu erhöhen nicht weiter
im weg stehen und dieses geld muss jetzt
der staat liefern und dafür muss auch
christian lindner endlich antworten
liefern tatsächlich hat die fdp die
geringsten schwierigkeiten mit dem 100
milliarden koffern scholz zu lang ist
ein sondervermögen ist solange die
schuldenbremse bleibt aber bleibt sie
also zunächst mal ist ja so dass wir
dieses sondervermögen beten um den
kernhaushalt gerade nicht zu belasten
das gehört zu sparsame haushaltsführung
dazu wir sehen gerade das alle möglichen
parteien ihre bislang vertretenen
position neu bestimmen müssen das tun
wir als spd ganz offensichtlich gerade
wenn es um militärausgaben wenn es um
waffenlieferungen geht dann kann man
auch von anderen parteien erwarten dass
sie mit ihren heiligen kühen anders
umgehen als in den vergangenen jahren
putins krieg zwingt der ampel
entscheidungen auf die ihrem selbst bei
ihrer dna entgegenstehen die frage ist
nur wie lange wird die koalition dabei
kanzler scholz der regierung umstandslos
folgen
und zu gast bei uns im studio begrüße
ich die spd-vorsitzende guten preis
guten nachmittag kommt jetzt wird ihre
partei die spd zur aufrüstung partei 100
milliarden sondertopf sondervermögen für
rüstung jahr für jahr für jahr über zwei
prozent auch für rüstung selbst wenn die
parteispitze diesen quantensprung
nachvollziehen kann oder vollziehen kann
was macht das mit der dna ihrer partei
die spd war in ihren 160 jahren ihres
bestehens immer eine friedenspartei die
in friedens begriff auch sehr nachhaltig
sind sehr umfassend ausgelegt hat da
ging es immer darum dass internationale
gerechtigkeit dass die freundschaft der
völker das aber auch das völkerrecht als
regelwerk und unsere in europäische
friedensordnung dass die basis dieses
friedens in rüstung und dazu gehört eben
auch die wehrhaftigkeit unsere
demokratie muss nicht nur nach innen sie
muss auch nach außen bedacht sein und
die spd hat mit vielen
verteidigungsministern und auch mit
vielen kanzlern gezeigt dass sie
verantwortung übernehmen kann in
situationen wo es notwendig ist jetzt
hat olaf schulz ja zurecht vollkommen zu
recht von einer zeitenwende gesprochen
und diese zeitenwende markiert eben auch
einen moment wo auch spd auch andere
parteien sich mit der realität
auseinandersetzen müssen und auch
antworten darauf geben dass sie sprechen
von einem moment aber wird dieses von
putin etablierte recht des stärkeren
wird das auf lange zeit die außen und
sicherheitspolitik auch der spd
verändern ja genau die ist es recht der
stärkeren des stärkeren darf eben nicht
die rolle spielen darf nicht eine höhere
wertigkeit bekommen als das völkerrecht
und unsere europäische friedensordnung
die mag sich weiterentwickeln müssen und
das wird auch in den nächsten wochen und
monaten zu debattieren sein aber es ist
ganz klar das recht des stärkeren als
overrule im moment das müssen wir
tatsächlich zurückweisen sollen diese
100 milliarden in diesem sondervermögen
sollen die ausschließlich für rüstung
ausgegeben werden oder auch für andere
projekte für entwicklungshilfe oder auch
klimakrise die klimakrise die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit viele andere
projekte die mit diesem genauer
nachhaltigen friedens begriff eben auch
zu tun haben natürlich auch der soziale
zusammenhalt in unserem land in europa
das sind weitere wichtige schwerpunkte
unserer politik die aber ja auch ganz
allgemein im haushalt bereits verankert
sind die wir in anderen sondervermögen
wenn sie ans klima denken auch verankert
haben und deswegen kommt es jetzt darauf
an dass wir im parlamentarischen
verfahren wo ja auch die union sich
bereit erklärt hat dieses sondervermögen
mit zu unterstützen aber eben auch
mitzugestalten
da kommt es jetzt darauf an dass wir
gemeinsam entwickeln was darin stecken
sondern weil so gibt es forderungen über
auf seiten der grünen beispielsweise
dass man dort auch andere verwendungen
als nur rüstung von diesen 100
milliarden will sie sagen ganz klar das
sind gelder für die rüstung ich sage
ganz klar das ist teil des
parlamentarischen aufgabe des
parlamentarischen verfahrens debattieren
nicht wir beide sondern das debattiert
das parlament und das werden wir in
aller ruhe auch gemeinsam auf den weg
bringt aber dann noch mal umgekehrt das
heißt also die ist es nicht ganz klar
definiert dass die nur für rüstung sind
denn das hat der kanzler ja gesagt es
ist ein assist zur ausstattung der der
bundeswehr gedacht unsere bundeswehr
muss unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
müssen um ihrer aufgabe gerecht zu
werden vor allem auch der
landesverteidigung der
bündnisverteidigung müssen die
entsprechend ausgestattet sein dass wir
brauchen schiffe die in see stechen
können wir brauchen flugzeuge die
fliegen da muss massiv investiert werden
aber die bundeswehr muss eben auch in
ihrer struktur so aufgestellt sein dass
sie das leisten kann das ist eine große
aufgabe ich bin sehr froh dass christine
lambrecht dass wir mit christine
lambrecht sozialdemokrat ich habe es
immer so dass ganz verstanden also 700
milliarden jetzt nur für rüstung oder
ist da auch anderes möglich wenn das
parlament das möchte das muss das
parlament entscheiden das ist in jedem
fall aufgabe des parlamentes jetzt zu
definieren wofür wir dieses
sondervermögen ausgeben aber ganz klar
es geht um die ausrüstungen es geht um
die befähigung der bundeswehr brauchen
wir weitere zusätzliche massive mittel
für die flüchtlinge wir werden die die
flüchtlinge die jetzt aus der ukraine
schützt vor dem krieg zuflucht vor dem
krieg suchen ja hier in deutschland und
in europa aufnehmen ich bin sehr froh
dass es gelungen ist sehr schnell mit
den europäischen mitgliedsstaaten ein
gemeinsames und gleiches verfahren zu
finden nach einem
rechtsbegriff den wir nach dem
balkankrieg geschaffen haben dass wir
jetzt sehr um kroatisch die leute auch
aufnehmen können und versorgen können
und da mussten müssen natürlich die
geldmittel auch bereitgestellt werden
damit die versorgung möglich ist ganz
entscheiden kommt es darauf an dass die
menschen krankenversicherung haben und
es wird auch darauf ankommen dass sie
zugang zum arbeitsmarkt bekommt preis
ging auf die letzte frage haben sie
sicher schon gewartet gerhard schröder
wurde von der ehrengalerie ihrer partei
gestrichen
relativ leise und unauffällig online ist
es also vollzogen was erwarten sie im
wirklichen leben von gerd schröter wir
haben gerhard schröder gegenüber lars
klingbeil und ich ganz klar deutlich
gemacht dass wir von ihm erwarten dass
er seine mandate beim russischen
unternehmen zurückgibt russische
unternehmen die jetzt teil der kriegs
infrastruktur sind haben sie denn neun
mark man macht keine geschäfte mit einem
diktator mit einem kriegstreiber das ist
ganz klar unsere haltung wir haben
bisher keine antwort bekommen wir
erwarten zeitnah eine antwort ich danke
ihnen für das gespräch
wenn jetzt 100 milliarden euro für
rüstung bereitgestellt werden dann lohnt
sich ein kritischer blick denn schon in
den vergangenen fünf jahren wuchs der
rüstungs haushalt von 37 auf 50
milliarden und dennoch ist die
bundeswehr in einem desaströsen zustand
steht blank da wie es der inspekteur des
heeres formuliert es fallen stichworte
wie bürokratie und beschaffungsamt
mathis feldhoff hat sich die probleme
genauer
[Musik]
er ist wahrscheinlich der beste
schützenpanzer der welt der puma das
haupt waffensystem der grenadier truppe
der bundeswehr mit sicherheit ist dabei
der teuerste vor 25 jahren entwickelt
und bestellt hat die bundeswehr heute
350 stück von puma und könnte dennoch
damit nicht in den krieg ziehen
der puma ist ein gutes beispiel für das
was falsch läuft also da wird erst etwas
gefordert was schon aufwendig genug ist
und auch richtig teuer wird der teuerste
schützenpanzer welt dann ist er da und
dann stellt man fest damit auch
eingesetzt werden kann für die nato
aufgaben die er hat muss er noch mal für
das gleiche geld nachgerüstet werden die
ist krieg in europa und
wir sind nicht in der lage einen
wirklich angemessenen beitrag zur
landes- und bündnisverteidigung der nato
zu leisten
[Musik]
das ist die traurige wahrheit deutschen
rüstungspolitik die hier ihre heimat hat
im bendlerblock den deutschen
verteidigungsministerium haben sie
erstmals seit jahrzehnten keine
geldsorgen
fieberhaft denkt die generalität darüber
nach wie man 100 milliarden euro
ausgeben kann ohne die fehler der
letzten jahrzehnte zu wiederholen
wir müssen weg von goldrand lösungen
jeden fall und wir können jetzt auch
beim schnellen herstellung der
einsatzbereitschaft jetzt nicht
europäische vergabeverfahren durchziehen
die jahrelang dauern das geht nicht und
die bundeswehr hat übung darin sich und
der öffentlichkeit in die tasche zu
lügen im halbjährlichen rüstungsbericht
gibt man sich noch im november des
letzten jahres optimistisch beim
schützenpanzer puma gibt es eine
positive entwicklung
doch tatsächlich sind von den 350 puma
die die bundeswehr derzeit hat nur 40
auf dem stand gefechts fähig zu sein
oder wie die industrie es nennt kriegs
fähig das der puma und moderner
schützenpanzer zum teil nach zivilen
standards gebaut worden ist ist ein
irrsinn den keine andere nation der welt
so macht so dürfen im hinteren krampf
raum nur soldaten unter 1 meter 84 platz
nehmen co2 sensoren wachen über die
gesundheit die arbeitsstättenverordnung
lässt grüßen
jetzt rüstet die industrie nach und den
puma auf ein rundum sicht system eine
panzerabwehrwaffe und digitalfunk bis
der kriegs wege puma in nennenswerten
stückzahlen zur verfügung steht dauert
es bis mindestens zum jahr 2027
das großgerät der bundeswehr ist eine
ansammlung von beschaffungs miseren seit
1972 seit 50 jahren fliegt zum transport
der truppe die ch 53
ein hubschrauber der inzwischen mehr
wartungs als flugstunden hat dass dieser
hubschraubertyp schon von den
amerikanern in vietnam krieg geflogen
wurde ist dabei mehr als eine historisch
an active
hier kann selbst die bundeswehrführung
nicht mehr drum herum reden der
flugbetrieb ist nur noch mit hohem
aufwand aufrechtzuerhalten so steht es
im material wirklich
längst hat es angebote und
ausschreibungen gegeben zwei
amerikanischer modelle standen und
stehen zur auswahl die ch-53 k und das
konkurrenzmodell die kinos 47 f nur die
deutsche entscheidung sie fehlt also
wenn es für die amerikaner gut ist also
wird die bundeswehr damit wahrscheinlich
auch zurechtkommen aber es wurde dann so
teuer dass man keine entscheidung
getroffen hat
in diesem gebäude sitzt das
beschaffungsamt der bundeswehr über
10.000 mitarbeiter kaufen von koblenz
aus alles ein was die truppe braucht ein
gefesselter riese der oft als übel der
misere gilt das problem ist bloß dass
die vorschriften die gemacht werden die
aus dem bundestag kommen ihnen natürlich
viel handschellen anlegen und die
politische führung des ministeriums
müsste sie im grunde genommen dabei
unterstützen zu sagen seid doch mal
bereit mehr risiko einzugehen
unzählige reformversuche der letzten
jahre aber haben die beschaffung in der
bundeswehr immer nur verkompliziert mehr
bürokratie kompliziertere verträge mehr
zeitverlust wenn man jetzt den zustand
der bundeswehr sieht ist es schon eine
notstandssituation wo man wirklich auch
aus dem kanzleramt herauf genau
hinschauen muss was mit dem geld
passiert eine entscheidung scheint der
kanzler bereits getroffen zu haben die
nachfolge des tornados auch der deutsche
kampfbomber ist in die jahre gekommen
die einsatzbereitschaft kann nur noch
mit hohem aufwand sichergestellt werden
damit würde eine der wichtigsten aber
auch umstrittensten fähigkeiten der
bundeswehr auch künftig möglich der
einsatz von amerikanischen atomwaffen
durch deutsche flugzeuge die wahl
scheint auf ein amerikanisches modell
gefallen keine überraschung schon lange
ist die f35 in der diskussion ein kauf
dieses bereits erprobten tarnkappen
bomber das macht hoffnung bei seiner
anschaffung schneller geht als sonst
üblich die nukleare teilhabe bleibt
bestehen also ich denke dass es möglich
ist so etwas wie der 35 innerhalb
bis 20 28 tatsächlich die ersten systeme
auf dem hof zu haben und das wäre für
uns günstig denn wir haben keine gewähr
dass der tornado oder die tornados die
wir noch haben tatsächlich bis 20.30 uhr
fliegen man kann nur hoffen dass wir
nach dieser aggression russlands
gegenüber der ukraine zeit genug haben
zum herstellen der einsatzbereitschaft
wir sollten diese zeit nicht verspielen
[Musik]
hinter den fenstern des
verteidigungsministeriums wird derzeit
fieberhaft gedacht und geplant wie gibt
man 100 milliarden aus wunschlisten sind
schnell gefüllt die tatsächliche
beschaffung ist nicht nur ein kraftakt
sondern ein kulturwandel für eine sehr
eingefahrene truppe
krieg war schon immer eine katharsis
eine zeit für große veränderung in
deutschland sagt der grüne wirtschaft
und klimaminister die
versorgungssicherheit sei wichtiger als
die klimakrise es gebe keine denk tabus
mehr dazu zählt des kriegs kröten wie
verlängerte laufzeiten für
kohlekraftwerke von den grünen
geschluckt werden könnten paradoxien
einer politischen krise britta buchholz
über die energiewende in zeiten des
krieges
die atomkraft in deutschland war
geschichte der kohleausstieg
beschlossene sache doch nun muss die
energiewende neu gedacht werden
denn während putins armee die ukraine
dem erdboden gleichmacht kaufen wir
weiter aus russland kohle öl und gas
aus geopolitischer sicht sehen wir dass
die abhängigkeit von russland nicht nur
uns angreifbar macht sondern dass wir
dadurch auch mit unseren geldern diesen
krieg diesen furchtbaren angriffskrieg
von putin mitfinanzieren das wollen wir
nicht und deshalb versuchen wir jetzt so
viel wie möglich zu reduzieren so
schnell wie möglich unabhängig zu werden
unabhängig werden immer noch kommt 55
prozent des gelieferten erdgases aus
russland
also man muss jetzt eigentlich so planen
als ob es kein gas aus russland gäbe
entweder weil russland den gashahn zu
gemacht oder weil wir uns entschließen
eben kein gas mehr abzunehmen doch
gleichzeitig geht ein meiler nach dem
nächsten vom netz schon in drei wochen
schaltet das braunkohlekraftwerk neurath
a abt
anfang der woche treffen sich die ost
ministerpräsidenten aus den braunkohle
gebieten es geht eigentlich um die
zukunft der lausitz doch in anbetracht
des krieges geht es plötzlich um eine
renaissance der kohle
wir haben braunkohlekraftwerke die
stabil arbeiten und das darf jetzt nicht
abgeschaltet werden und damit noch mehr
die abhängigkeit von russischem gas
erzeugt werden wir müssen wir klug
miteinander nachdenken und ich wünsche
mir da eine wirkliche diskussion ohne
scheuklappen
wir brauchen im revier sicherheit für
die beschäftigten die menschen müssen
wissen woran sie sind und wir brauchen
auch für die unternehmen
planungssicherheit
ich persönlich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass wir die braunkohle deutlich länger
brauchen werden 2030 der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel ist deutlich
ein beschleunigter ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung soll idealerweise bis
20.30 erfolgen ein hart erkämpftes ziel
der grünen und nicht alle wollen an
diesem rütteln
für uns ist klar dass wir am
kohleausstieg bis 20.30 festhalten weil
es gerade die abhängigkeit von den
fossilen ist die uns angreifbar gemacht
haben bliebe die renaissance der
atomkraft von der viele nichts wissen
wollen für die letzten drei
kernkraftwerke sollte ende des jahres
schluss sein der wirtschaftsminister
habe prüft nun ob sie länger am netz
bleiben könnten die betreiber
signalisieren gesprächsbereitschaft
habeck hat so eine schwierige debatte
losgetreten die partei bemüht sich ihre
minister nicht in den rücken zu fallen
die grüne umweltministerin hält eine
verlängerung für nicht verantwortbar und
sagt das anders mittel und langfristig
bleibt der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien das absolut entscheidende und
unabhängiger von importen zu werden und
auch daran arbeitet die bundesregierung
natürlich absolut zielstrebig und
energisch
doch die erneuerbaren energien können
bisher schwerlich russische importe
ausgleichen außerdem sind sie oft noch
sehr teuer und es bleibt ein kernproblem
der ausbau geht voran aber viel zu
langsam
es hapert insbesondere tatsächlich an
den genehmigungsverfahren und die müssen
jetzt ganz schnell bestraft werden hier
muss man tempo rein bringen denn
erneuerbare sind ja jetzt sehr sehr
attraktiv ökonomisch schauen sie sich
die hohen strompreise an das heißt
dieses wirtschaftliche argument für die
erneuerbaren das ist jetzt wirklich da
die zahlen zeigen es im bereich strom
wurde viel geschafft deutschland bezieht
ihn derzeit fast zur hälfte aus
erneuerbaren energien
doch im bereich wärme also zum heizen
tragen die erneuerbaren kaum bei gerade
hier muss eine alternative zum
russischen erdgas her
so wie zum beispiel flüssiggas
sogenanntes allen schien es kommt per
schiff aus usa katar oder australien und
wird auch im fracking verfahren
gefördert viele lehnen das ab zu
gefährlich und zu klimaschädlich die
ampel will es dennoch die opposition
bezweifelt ob die grünen diesen spagat
schaffen werden ich denke schon dass es
jetzt für einige grüne wirklich darum
geht möglichst schnell in der realität
anzukommen und nicht mehr im
wolkenkuckucksheim unterwegs zu sein das
war vorher schon falsch und das wird
natürlich durch diesen krieg und durch
diese energie versorgungs krise die uns
droht noch tragischer
die atomkraft in deutschland war
geschichte der kohleausstieg
beschlossene sache jetzt müssen alle die
energiewende neu denken
und aus flensburg zugeschaltet ist uns
der vizekanzler und wirtschafts und
klimaminister guten tag herr beck
schauen wir zunächst das thema
energiesicherheit wir haben in der
ukraine gesehen dass selbst
atomkraftwerke unter beschuss geraten
sind sie für das endgültige atomausstieg
verlangt doch denkbar ich bin natürlich
dafür den ausstieg aus der atomkraft
möglichst schnell zu vollenden wir haben
falls die lieferketten aus russland
reißen eine herausforderung für den
nächsten winter im frühjahr das frühjahr
und den sommer werden wir gut bestehen
können aber der nächste winter bereitet
mir noch ein bisschen sorgen wir prüfen
deswegen obwohl ich natürlich für den
ausstieg aus der atomenergie bin ob ein
längerer betrieb der atomkraftwerke
irgendwas nutzen würde aber nach dem was
man absehen kann ist das nicht der fall
stichwort kohle nicht zuletzt auch den
kohleländern kommen forderung nach
laufzeitverlängerung der kohlekraftwerke
ist der ausstieg 2030 weiter gesetzt
oder würden sie beispielsweise auch
zusätzliche kohlekraftwerke in die
sicherheits bereitschaft aufnehmen
noch einmal wir reden jetzt nur über den
hypothetischen fall dass die
lieferketten von gas oder kohle oder öl
aus russland reisen oder sanktioniert
werden da sind wir ja noch nicht für
diesen fall hilft uns ein längerer
betrieb von steinkohle überhaupt nicht
weiter weil wir ja von steinkohle
importen abhängig sind das ist ja gerade
das problem und bei braunkohle muss man
sehr vorsichtig sein denn das ist nun
die klimaschädlichste energieformen die
wir haben wir haben ja die andere krise
die wir nicht aus dem kopf verlieren
dürfen und wir müssen darauf hinarbeiten
möglichst unabhängig von fossilen
energien zu werden deswegen ist es eine
möglichkeit kraftwerke in der reserve zu
halten für den fall der fälle der bisher
noch nicht eingetreten ist und
hoffentlich nicht eintreten wird aber
für den fall der fälle aber sie sollten
nicht weiter laufen in der reserve heißt
sie werden vorgehalten sie werden nicht
verschrottet aber sie sind nicht mehr in
betrieb es gibt heute berichte ihr
ministerium prüfe beispielsweise eine
solardach pflicht für neubauten wollen
sie das was ist da verabredet im
koalitionsvertrag für bürogebäude und
gewerbegebäude soll es eine pflicht
geben und für neubauten im privaten
bereich eine soll bestimmung das heißt
es etwas weicher aber die erwartung ist
eigentlich und wie könnte man einer zeit
wie dieser auf was anderes kommen dass
auf jedes haus neu gebaut wird einen
solar nachkommt nun sagt der
haushaltspolitische sprecher ihrer
fraktion kindler des 100 milliarden
paket und das zwei prozent ziel sei in
frage zu stellen es sei falsch den
sicherheitsbegriff auf die bundeswehr zu
verengen teilen sie seine haltung
die bundeswehr ist unter ausgestattet
wir brauchen in zeiten wie diesen eine
funktionstüchtige und einsatzfähiger 1
media gibt es gar keine frage wir wissen
aber auch dass natürlich sicherheit
nicht nur militärisch gewährleistet wird
sondern durch vorbeugende maßnahmen
erhöht wird die energiesicherheit gehört
beispielsweise dazu nun will ich nicht
alles miteinander vermengen aber ich
würde sagen das eine tun und das andere
nicht lassen das ist die richtige maxime
aber in seiner rede sprach der kanzler
ausdrücklich von der bundeswehr sagte
bessere ausrüstung modernen das
einsatzgerät mehr personal soll dieses
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden auch
in energieumbau fließen und nicht nur in
militärische sicherheit
nein das soll es nicht wir haben ja für
den energiebereich einen anderen topf
den klima und transformations- vor der
aufbau ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
wird privat investiert es gibt die
möglichkeit öffentliche
investitionsgesellschaften in dem
bereich zu gründen also da haben wir
andere möglichkeiten ein das soll es
nicht die 100 milliarden sind für die
militärische der fähigkeit deutschlands
reserviert aber das ist eine klare
absage an ihre an ihre mit
parteigenossen hätte ich fast gesagt
dass dieser topf von 100 jahre ich sage
ich sagte ja das eine tun und das andere
nicht lassen natürlich brauchen wir auch
mittel in die zivile krisenprävention in
die konfliktbewältigung bevor menschen
aufeinander schießen oder das aufrüsten
beginnt das kann doch nicht strittig
seien an dieser stelle und wie die 100
milliarden verausgabt werden das ist ja
auch noch eine frage fließen sie in
jährlich gleichen scheiben ab für welche
projekte werden sie vorbehalten machen
wir unsinnige ausgaben oder kooperieren
wir besser mit den europäischen partnern
das ist ja alles noch zu prüfen und im
detail dann zu regeln das heißt also zu
investieren in die bundeswehr aber auch
in die zivile krisenprävention in die
humanitäre hilfe in das abschwellen
lassen von krisen bevor menschen sterben
müssen das sind ja keine widersprüche
nochmal zur klarstellung auch aus diesen
100 milliarden
wissen sie ich würde immer sagen das was
nötig ist muss getan werden wenn die
bundeswehr nur 90 milliarden braucht
dann freue ich mich wenn sie 110
milliarden braucht aber auch sie halt
110 milliarden es ist ja nicht
akzeptabel dass irgendwelche
fahrzeuge im schuppen stehen die nicht
einsatzfähig sind umgekehrt brauchen wir
natürlich die gelder die ist die
notwendig sind das krisen gar nicht
entstehen also die haushalterische
debatte finde ich ist da überhaupt nicht
zielführend das was notwendig ist in
einer zeit wie dieser in einer
krisenanfälligen zeit wie dieser muss
getan werden im energiebereich in der
transformation in der unabhängigkeit von
fossilen energien um der fähigkeit von
militärischen möglichkeiten der armee
aber eben auch in der zivilen
krisenprävention aber schauen wir auf
den krieg in unserer nachbarschaft putin
lebt ja das recht des stärkeren brauchen
wir in europa eine eigene nukleare
abschreckung man stelle sich mal vor
donald trump würde wiedergewählt werden
wir sehen wie wichtig die nato ist und
die nato ist ein arbeitsteiliges bündnis
und in dieser in diesem bündnis muss
jeder partner nach seinen möglichkeiten
seinen beitrag leisten das heißt aber
auch nicht dass alle alles leisten
müssen und vor allem würde ich sagen
auch wenn ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe
die armee muss
einsatzbereit sein und einsatzfähig sein
wir müssen natürlich auch sehr aufpassen
jetzt nicht das kind mit dem bade
auszuschütten eine auf rüstungsspirale
reinzukommen wir sehen ja nun gerade in
der ukraine wie gefährlich atomwaffen
sind das in einer zeit leben mit dem
einsatz gedroht wird deswegen würde ich
sagen die chance für die diplomatie die
darf man nicht aus dem auge verlieren
und jetzt nicht
unbedacht
versuchen eine eine eine kulisse
aufzubauen die uns eine neue atomare
aufrüstung spirale bringt haben wir
werden ja zeuge einer neuentstehenden
weltordnung auch den stärkeren zerfall
in blöcke ist nach sicht des
wirtschaftsministers die zeit der
globalisierung so wie wir sie kennen
vorbei
was man sehe ich keine blöcke ich sehe
ein isoliertes russland und zwar ein so
isoliertes russland das die wirtschaft
wankt in der stadt das von allen
finanzströmen abgestritten im grunde ist
russland bankrott und insel und wir
werden sehen wie sich das in zukunft
dann auch auf die politische situation
in dem land auswirkt ich will an einer
globalisierung festhalten die durch den
handel der welt und der verständigung
der menschen den offenen grenzen einen
beitrag zu frieden leistet wir sehen
dass wir präsidenten brauchen dass wir
uns breiter aufstellen müssen dass wir
nicht im vertrauen auf ein land und
ehrlicherweise unter uns jetzt so
überraschend dass putin kein
verlässlicher partner ist das ja nun
auch nicht die einzige das nicht kapiert
hat dass gerhard schröder in der
vergangenheit gewesen also wir können
nicht alle unsere chips auf eine karte
setzen aber festhalten daran dass wir
miteinander kooperieren in dieser welt
im handel aber auch politisch das ist
doch das gebot der stunde
herberg ich danke ihnen für das gespräch
ich danke
das gespräch haben wir aus termingründen
aufgezeichnet das war berlin direkt und
hier geht es jetzt sofort weiter im zdf
spezial mit keeper vielen dank theo koll
bisher zeigte sich der russische
präsident wladimir putin weiter unbeirrt
beharrt auf seinen forderungen nur dann
würden die kampfhandlungen aufhören und
so geht der krieg gnadenlos weiter was
heute passiert ist anne brühl und
stephanie festen meier mit einem
überblick
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die herrlichkeit und der wille der
ukraine sind nicht gestorben es ist die
ukrainische nationalhymne die die kinder
singen sie haben zuflucht gefunden in
liv in der west ukraine sechs tage und
sechs nächte in der umkämpften
hauptstadt kiew liegen hinter ihnen
stecken und militärflugzeuge so gab
explosionen schulkinder haben das alles
gehört wir haben im keller unserer
schulische schlag
für die kinder soll es weiter gehen raus
aus der ukraine aus einem land in dem
krieg herrscht
ich weiß dass russland die ukraine zapfe
ich weiß dass der russische präsident
dem krieg nicht stoppen sind das ist
alles
die sirenen waren auch an diesem morgen
in kiew wieder vor luftangriffen
[Musik]
aus der region um die hauptstadt werden
schwere kämpfe gemeldet besonders
umkämpft ist ihn westlich von kiew
er liegt immer noch unter heftigem
beschuss immer wieder werden auch in
wohngebiete getroffen
strategisch ist die stadt wichtig für
die russen die den ring um kiew immer
enger ziehen wollen
47 tausend einwohner hat ihn die meisten
sind inzwischen auf der flucht
erst dann haben sie tag und nacht unter
feuer genommen sie haben das krankenhaus
das steuerbüro getroffen und der
beschuss geht weiter
der abwehrkampf der ukraine rund um hier
wird immer verzweifelter
selbstgebaute panzersperren sollen den
vormarsch der russen aufhalten auch die
appelle des präsidenten werden
verzweifelter zielinski meldet sich auch
heute per handy video sieht nach wie vor
eine flugverbotszone als einzige rettung
wenn wir uns nicht wenigstens flugzeuge
geht damit wir uns verteidigen können
dann können wir daraus noch einen
schluss ziehen dass ihr wollt so dass
wir langsam getötet werden
die verantwortung von politikern auf der
ganzen welt
aus dem russischen
verteidigungsministerium kommen diese
bilder kampfjets die ukrainische ziele
ins visier nehmen die luftwaffe heißt es
ziehe sich zurück und bodentruppen platz
zu machen unabhängig überprüfen lassen
sich diese angaben nicht
das sind die letzten bilder die uns aus
mario pohl erreicht habe heftige kämpfe
erschüttern die stadt der bürgermeister
meldet sich mit einem verzweifelten
appell in
den ersten tagen des krieges handeln
wird dutzende opfer dann hunderte und in
zwei tagen wahrscheinlich tausende sie
geben uns noch nicht mal die möglichkeit
die verwundeten und die toten zu zählen
bei der beschuss in den letzten sechs
tagen niemals aufgehört hat
mario pohl liegt im süden der ukraine am
asowschen meer
440.000 einwohner hat die stadt die
hälfte davon wartet auf die evakuierung
in sapporo rund 250 kilometer entfernt
stehen busse bereit die die flüchtlinge
aufnehmen sollten eine evakuierung die
auch heute gescheitert ist der russische
präsident putin macht dafür die ukraine
verantwortlich
es gab schon gestern den versuch einer
evakuierung aber die kämpfe dauern an
auf den westen des landes richtet sich
die hoffnung von so vielen liv das alte
lemberg liegt nur 70 kilometer entfernt
von der polnischen grenze auch hier ist
der krieg längst angekommen checkpoints
barrikaden luftalarm aber keine direkten
kämpfe und mittendrin eine hochzeit
irina und bogdan glauben an die zukunft
für sich und für irland
[Musik]
schwierige zeiten aber wir sind
optimistisch wir kämpfen sind stark wir
werden gewinnen wir helfen mit allem was
möglich ist um diese invasion zu
bekämpfen
viele ihrer landsleute aber wollen nur
eins in sicherheit sicherheit die sie in
der ukraine im moment nicht finden
können
ja und in der ukraine in lemberg ist für
uns armin coerper was wissen sie denn
über die lage in den umkämpften gebieten
die russischen streitkräfte haben
gemeinsam mit den pro russischen
separatisten im osten des landes heute
an die 15 ortschaften eingenommen das
heißt von dort rücken sie weiter vor
auch in der hauptstadt kiew höre ich
heute abend von starken kämpfen
insbesondere im norden des landes
braucht viele zivilisten betroffen sind
die luftangriffe gehen weiter auf städte
bierhoff und vor allem mario pohl haben
wir gerade in dem beitrag schon gehört
die vereinbarte feuerpause für heute und
der humanitären korridor wurden wieder
nicht eingehalten statt der erhofften
200.000 menschen die diese stadt heute
sicher verlassen sollten haben das
gerade mal 300 geschafft viele
hilfsgüter sind hier mittlerweile
lembeck wie kommen die denn in die
städte die direkt unter beschuss stehen
genau das ist das große problem also
lemberg hier ist ein umschlagplatz für
hilfsgüter die aus ganz europa hierher
kommen die werden hier um gepackt und
mit kleineren transportern in
verschiedene regionen dieses sehr sehr
großen landes gebracht die infrastruktur
der ukraine ist auch in friedenszeiten
sehr schlecht das heißt die straßen sind
schlecht passierbar jetzt ist sind weite
teile des landes unter beschuss das
heißt diese konvois brauchen so höre ich
in der regel bis zu vier tagen um
überhaupt irgendwo in richtung archiv
mario pohl und so weiter um dort
irgendwo anzukommen was dringend
benötigt wird sind wasser vor allem
medizinische also medikamente
medizinisches verbands und
versorgungsmaterial
denn selbst hier in lemberg in der
westukraine ihnen sind die apotheken
langsam leer und es fehlt an
medikamenten in den umkämpften orten die
er zum teil wie mario weber gerade schon
gesehen haben seit tagen von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten sind da kommt ja
keinerlei medizinische versorgung mehr
rein das sind menschen die krank sind
vom krieg unabhängig krebspatienten zum
beispiel die dringend auf medizinische
versorgung und medikamente warten und
darauf angewiesen sind vielen dank für
diese information aus der ukraine
armin coerper
unterdessen erklärt wladimir putin es
lief alles nach plan der westen reagiert
weiter mit sanktionen inzwischen haben
auch die größten kreditkartenanbieter
mastercard und visa ihre internationalen
geschäfte mit russland ausgesetzt und in
russland selbst gibt es trotz drohender
strafen weiter proteste etwa 3500 russen
sollen heute verhaftet worden sein als
verstorben über den krieg den putin
nicht nur gegen die ukraine sondern auch
gegen sein volk führt
moskau heute vormittag vor dem
nationalen historischen museum am roten
platz greifen sie wieder zu putins auf
räumtrupps
greifen nach den wenigen menschen die
sich trauen hier
keinen krieg zu rufen welche strafen
drohen in einem land das krieg führt
ohne rechtssicherheit steht in den
sternen jeden tag gibt es demos zurzeit
in russland auch gestern abend
bitte sehen sie sich das an hier mitten
in moskau auf dem puschkin-platz findet
eine nicht genehmigte demo statt
viele menschen sind gekommen
putin hat große angst davor dass die
leute ihre stimme erheben und verlangen
dass er den krieg beendet
deutlich sichtbar in diesen tagen es ist
das regime das krieg führt viele
russinnen und russen lehnen ihn ab gehen
auf die straße im ganzen land wie hier
in tomsk in mehr als 100 städten gab es
bereits anti kriegs demos und seit
beginn des konflikts tausende festnahmen
während die einen in gewahrsam genommen
werden gibt es auch pinsel ein für die
anderen zu sehen auf diesen inszenierten
bildern komplimente überbrachte
persönlich vom präsidenten der bei
dieser gelegenheit nebenbei der ukraine
mit der auslöschung droht
ich habe das bereits gesagt wenn die
ukrainische führung weiter tut was ihr
tut bringt sie die existenz ihres landes
in gefahr und wenn das passiert
auf ihrem konto ist nicht die frage der
sogenannten volksrepublik lohans stolz
geschwenkt in sankt petersburg für die
kameras des russischen staatsfernsehens
putins propaganda kanäle tun alles um
das bild eines volkes zu zeichnen dass
hinter dem angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
steht der buchstabe z der auf den
russischen panzern prangt er steht wohl
für papier für den sieg die nachricht
die so genannte spezialoperation sei
richtig und wichtig wie groß aber die
unterstützung für den russischen
waffengang wirklich ist zeigen diese
inszenierten bilder nicht aber diese
szenen sind authentisch die ukrainische
flagge über dem bahnhof von helsinki
russinnen und russen die nichts wollen
als ihr land verlassen raus aus russland
mit dem zug nach finnland noch geht das
wir mussten unseren flug umbuchen alles
ist sehr schwierig gerade weil die
beziehung zwischen zwei guten ländern
nicht mehr gut ist ich hoffe dass es
bald besser wird
zwei züge am tag gibt es von petersburg
nach helsinki alle ausgebucht seit tagen
immer mehr airlines stornieren ihre
flüge
wir planen zurzeit eine zusätzliche
zugverbindung am tag von sankt
petersburg nach helsinki anzubieten
darüber verhandeln wir gerade mit den
staatlichen behörden
wir hoffen dass das vielleicht schon in
der kommenden woche umsetzbar ist
finnland wird zu einem fluchtpunkt für
russinnen und russen deren
reisemöglichkeiten immer stärker
eingeschränkt werden
ja und über die lage in russland
sprechen wir jetzt mit dem ehemaligen
deutschen botschafter in moskau rüdiger
von fritsch guten abend
herr
von fritsch spaß erfahren sie aus
russland wie ist die lage dort im moment
es sind sehr traurige ja schrecklichen
nachrichten die in diesen tagen bei
freunden bekannten auch bei mir selber
eingehende sind nachrichten von
schlimmer repression und auch hilferufe
von
schriftstellern von geistlichen von
menschenrechtsaktivisten und wir sind
zum ersten mal in einer situation in der
ein aderlass an intellektueller aderlass
russland droht wie zuletzt wohl
1917 selbst mutige menschen die zu
sowjetzeiten standgehalten haben sind
dabei das land zu verlassen und wir
sehen insgesamt dass er in einer
situation sind in der wir im übergang
sind von einem autoritär geführten land
hin zu einem diktatorisch geführten land
in dem jedem ein bekenntnis ab verlangt
wird auch heute gab es wieder proteste
und verhaftungen ab wann kann das denn
wladimir putin wirklich gefährlich
werden
man kann den mut dieser menschen nur
bewundern nicht die strafen sind gerade
auf bis zu 15 jahren für solche aktionen
hochgesetzt werden den mut derjenigen
die ihre freiheit ihre materielle
existenz ja auch ihre gesundheit
befürchten die handeln aus ihrem
gewissen heraus der große teil der
menschen jedoch kann zum einen sich
gegen die staatliche propaganda kaum
während deren opfer er ist und zum
anderen liest er sehr genau die signale
der repression und der angst die wieder
ausgesandt werden ich kann diese
menschen nur zu gut verstehen aber die
russische führung muss sehr gut im auge
behalten und davor hat sie
offensichtlich angst wann der punkt
gekommen ist wo die soziale und
wirtschaftliche lage der menschen so
schwierig wird dass sie doch plötzlich
massenhaft auf die straße gehen das ist
ein moment der für die führung dann doch
gefährlich werden könnte aber den würde
ich nicht unmittelbar jetzt sehen putin
hat ja heute gesagt dass laufe alles
nach plan wer oder was könnt ihr denn
überhaupt noch zum einlenken bringen
ja es läuft ja offensichtlich nicht nach
plan die russische führung hat sich wie
schon 2014 irgend einmal mehr verschätzt
ganz offensichtlich war man von einer
art blitzkrieg ausgegangen in dem man in
die ukraine vorstößt in kiew die führung
austauscht und dann werden die jubelnden
und begeisternden ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer mütterchen russland in die arme
laufen das gegenteil ist der fall und
mit jeder stunde mit jedem tag in dem
die ukraine ein jahr wirklich so helden
mutigen widerstand leisten wird es auch
für den russischen präsidenten ungleich
schwerer aus dieser situation wieder
herauszukommen denn er muss sich fragen
was will ich mit einer besetzten mit
einer annektierten ukraine mit menschen
die so gegen mich eingenommen sind
eigentlich anfangen selbst mit einer
marionettenregierung die schützen müsste
es gibt ja weiter internationale
diplomatische bemühungen auch heute
abend wieder durch den israelischen
ministerpräsidenten was meinen sie als
diplomat wie erfolgsversprechend ist
dass
das dilemma ist dass zwei völlig
unterschiedliche vorstellungen
aufeinander treffen auf der einen seite
die ukraine die nichts anderes verlangt
als einen waffenstillstand und bereits
zu sein zu gesprächen das ist das
mindeste um gespräche zu führen muss man
sagen man kann ja nicht unter laufendem
feuer verhandeln und auf der anderen
seite der russische präsident und es ist
sein handeln das ist nicht russland
dieses er auch wunderbare land dem ich
persönlichen sympathie verbunden bin
russland die russische führung die
ultimativ von der ukraine dinge verlangt
die die ukraine nicht bereit ist zu
erfüllen und in einer solchen situation
ist es schwer vorstellbar wo der
russische präsident bereit sein könnte
einzulenken und daher ist es auf der
einen seite sehr richtig anstrengungen
auch diplomatische art zu unternehmen
aber auf der anderen seite ist im moment
nicht die situation wo ein zeichen aus
moskau käme dass man bereit ist zu einer
friedlichen lösung dieses konfliktes
eine großmacht ist nicht bereit einen
krieg zu verlieren und ich fürchte der
russische präsident ist bereit ihn bis
zum ende durchzuziehen mit furchtbaren
opfern für die ukraine aber auch für
sein eigenes land keine guten
nachrichten vielen dank aber rüdiger von
fritsch von 2014 bis 2019 deutscher
botschafter in russland
und die vereinten nationen sprechen
inzwischen von der größten flüchtlings
kriege in europa seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg mit den vergangenen zehn tagen
haben mehr als 1,5 millionen ukraine
ihre heimat verlassen in deutschland ist
eine der zentralen anlaufstellen
frankfurt an der oder von dort berichtet
katrin lindner
die naroska übersetzers freiwillige
helferinnen auf dem bahnhof in frankfurt
oder die ukrainerin lebt seit 14 jahren
in brandenburg und will ihren
landsleuten helfen
ganze meine familie bleibt in der
ukraine und kommt keiner mein bruder
kämpft schon und zwei neffen sind 18 und
21 sie können nicht kommen die dürfen
nicht kommen und sie wollen nicht kommen
es geht um ehre und um alles die
passagiere diese sonderzugs aus polen
müssen umsteigen die bundespolizei
kontrolliert die pässe ukrainische
staatsbürger dürfen sofort weiter
shuttle züge der bahn stehen nach berlin
bereit diese frau ist mit vier kindern
geflohen vier tage lang
die eltern sind noch in der ukraine wir
wollen nach berlin weil es dort viele
ukraine gibt
ihre mutter ihr mann sind
zurückgeblieben sie hat nur noch tränen
wir wollen dass das alles aufhört wir
wollen keinen krieg wir wollen frieden
sagt sie
auf dem bahnsteig wartet auch stephanie
grabs aus neuzelle wir haben zimmer frei
haben zwei nagelneue ferienwohnungen und
mein traum ist es eigentlich heute hier
eine mutti mit drei kindern oder noch
eine oma oder somit zu nehmen und
einfach was gutes tun dieses
bereitschaft ist enorm vor allem
freiwillige haben bisher in frankfurt
oder die flüchtlinge begrüßt und
versorgt
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
oder auf der flucht helfen wollen dann
können sie spenden an das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe stichwort zdf nothilfe
ukraine bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 alle infos auch unter spenden zdf de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
das war unser zdf spezial am tag elf des
krieges an dem die lage für die menschen
in den umkämpften gebieten immer
dramatischer wird mehr informationen
später im heute-journal und gleich
danach in einem maybrit illner spezial
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
may-britt